>> From the Library of Congress in Washington,
D.C.
In today's complicated political environment,
one thing is certain - you need to know the
facts.
Where do you go to find -
What bills your Representative or Senator
introduced.
Current information about tax proposals.
Historical information about health care legislation.
Explanations of the legislative process and
current legislative activities.
For nearly two decades, the Library of Congress
has provided the nation's lawmakers, the American
People, and the world with free access to
non-biased and reliable legislative information.
But changing technology demands that system
evolve to keep up with how information is
accessed today.
The new Congress.gov is user friendly, easy-to-search
and makes legislative information more mobile
and shareable.
Whether you are a concerned citizen, journalist,
educator, student, or member of Congress...you
can see democracy at work-Congress.gov-Informing
Democracy.
This has been a presentation of the Library
of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.